let's consider what happens when we have
an object that's moving on a horizontal
surface so here's our object and here's
our surface now we want to look at a
special case where we're applying a
force F to the object and the object is
moving at a constant speed then what we
see here is that there has to be some
type of force that's opposing this
object the interaction between the
object and the surface that's
distributed over the surface for this
I'll write an arrow here to express that
force that's the tangential component of
the force the object is also pressing
down on the surface the surface is
pressing up on the object and so there's
another perpendicular force to the
surface which is referred to as the
normal force and the total vector sum of
these two forces the perpendicular part
the normal force and the tangential part
is referred to as the contact force this
is what we'll call kinetic friction now
when the object is moving at a constant
speed we know that from experiment that
the kinetic friction the magnitude is
proportional to the magnitude of the
normal force and the constant of
proportionality is called the
coefficient of kinetic friction now this
law is telling us something very
interesting that two key properties are
one that it's independent of the contact
area now what do we mean by that so
let's look at the following picture
suppose we have two objects of the same
mass on the surface we're applying a
force F and the contact area here a1 and
we have a similar object the same mass
on the same surface and both objects are
moving at a constant speed now these
objects have different areas of conte
a 1 and a 2 but the force necessary to
move the object that the constant speed
is the same and because of that the
kinetic friction is the same and that
indicates that it's independent of the
contact area and the other key property
here which will right over here is that
it's independent of the speed of the
object so we'll write that as
independent of the velocity and these
three properties of kinetic friction are
crucial for understanding the motion of
objects across the surface but we still
don't have a very good theoretical model
for explaining this although today
there's a lot of contemporary research
which has made a lot of progress in
understanding this interaction